bonsoir oui madame moore a dit il y un
souci est ce que je peux vous parler
bien sûr nous sommes 100 personnes
depuis des années je me sens seule je me
suis dit que la solitude vous pensez
peut-être aussi ça fait combien de temps
qu'on se connaît on est voisins depuis
combien de temps on ne se connaît pas
tant que ça apprenons à mieux nous
connaître
je ne veux pas que les gens s'imaginent
des choses déplacées vous savez comment
c'est ça à faire parler les gens
il ne s'agit pas de sexe c'est pour
passer le cap des nuits vous voyez je
crois que je trouverai le sommet s'il y
avait quelqu'un côté de moi quelqu'un de
gentil
[Musique]
vous réveillez un matin vous avez tous
le lendemain 9 tours
hu devraient les déjeuners au restant ça
me va très bien
peut-être que je mettrais quelque chose
de coloré tape à l'oeil
[Musique]
pourquoi moi j'ai toujours pensé vous
étiez quelqu'un de bien
quelqu'un de bien tout est mais pas de
remarquables
[Musique]
alors
dans la vie il ya des choses qui ne se
répare pas à ton avis qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire on pourrait essayer de
discuter
qu'est ce que tu en penses je trouve que
c'est une bonne idée
qui sait où ça pourrait nous
jeudi
[Musique]
j'ai appris